- Insert intro here, TikToks.
(woop)
- [Text To Speech] How different foods
pass through my intestines.
Pasta.
(grunting)
Taco Bell.
(laughing)
Dairy.
(crash)
- I guess someone's lactose intolerant.
- [Text To Speech] A single lettuce.
(laughing)
Beans.
(singing)
- Beans are good for your heart
because they have fiber.
You thought I was going
to say something else.
No, actually everything goes
through your digestive system like this
because of peristalsis.
- [Text To Speech] Only people
under the age of 25 can hear this sound.
- So I shouldn't be able to hear it
considering I'm older than 25.
I will not say how much older.
I hear it.
- [Text To Speech] Did you hear it?
- Yeah!
Does that mean I'm younger than 25?
My ears are younger than 25.
Honestly the most important thing
you can do to save your ears
to hear stuff like this,
not for this but for life.
Is to not listen to your headphones.
Especially the ones
that are noise canceling
or plug your ears at more than 60% volume.
But if you hang out to the 50, 60
that's the safe zone for your ears.
Trust me on this.
(techno music)
- Oh no, don't be.
We don't operate with butter knives.
Keep it away from your mouth.
A butter knife, not so sharp.
Scalpel on your tongue, no
bueno for a myriad of reasons.
(techno music)
- Our poll!
Our poll made it into a TikTok.
(laughing)
Meme game, fire.
Organ, brain, poll, fire.
No, because I think there
should be an organ Olympics.
Like if there was an Olympics.
Oh, Hey bear.
If there was an Olympics for something.
Bear would you participate
in the organ Olympics?
Bear, I would never harvest your organs.
I will not ever harvest you kidneys.
(beep)
- Six months ago, I went on a
journey to transform my body.
- That's what I've been doing.
(grunts)
- You have to wake up every single day.
- Oh wow.
- And put the work in.
- Wow.
- You have to want it.
You're going to feel the pain.
- That's pretty good.
- And that's exactly
why I haven't started.
This is my friend Oleg.
(laughing)
- That's funny, he got me.
I was about to give
him props and all that.
And Oleg is the Russian name
so shout out to my fellow Russki.
(speaking Russian)
(hiphop music)
Is that miracle whip?
Hot sauce?
A1 sauce.
Is this a meal time video?
Pam? No.
I've said before that you
are not a chicken in a pot.
You are not a chicken in a pot.
You are not a stove
but I wouldn't recommend
doing that on your skin.
It's going to make it all
sticky and clog your pores.
Trying to get some medical
information out to you.
And I'm just struggling hard on this one.
(sipping drink)
My boyfriend is over, got a little hickey.
- A hickey is really just
like a superficial bruise.
- This!
(whoa)
- That's an aggressive hickey.
- You're going to take a metal whisk.
And you're going to whisk your neck.
Like some fricking Sunday morning eggs.
- I would just take a cold
spoon and hold it there
like I would for any bruise.
And it would also go away.
I mean, essentially
what's happening here is
if it's a cold whisk better
because it's going to shunt away
some of that blood and
slow down the bruising.
By doing the whisking you're actually
breaking up the blood
that's already there.
I just wouldn't recommend it.
It's not a place that
you should be whisking.
It's not that serious.
Wear a scarf, turtlenecks,
turtlenecks are cool.
Ask The Rock.
- Okay guys I just
found a real life glitch
and I have to know if
anyone else can see it.
Okay, so you are going to
stare at this plus sign
in the middle of these two faces
and you're going to focus all
of your energy right there.
Let your eyes rest.
And as you were looking at this plus sign
the faces on the left and
right are going to start
to distort into some crazy
alien looking shapes.
And I have absolutely
no idea what's going on.
- What?
What is supposed to happen?
- [Sam] The faces didn't
seem strange to you?
- They did.
I just assumed that
they were strange faces.
- [Sam] Watch it back
and look at the faces.
- Oh, really?
- [Jason] As you were looking
at this plus sign the faces
on the left and right are
going to start to distort
into some crazy alien looking...
- Interesting.
I wonder why this happens.
I think it has something
to do with your eyes
focusing on a dark color
and then you're only paying
attention to the lighter
colors of the faces
and the way that they're shaded.
There's something happening here
that I can't explain quite well.
'Cause I'm a family medicine physician
and I need some kind of
evolutionary biologist here
to help me with this one.
Lifeline please.
(oh)
Okay, so I'm going to
show you guys something.
Let me know what you guys think.
- Wow she can suck in her stomach.
- [TikTok Background] Yo!
- I used to be able to
do that when I was a kid
and it freak everybody out.
Yeah, so she could suck in her abdomen
and kind of push all her
organs smooch them together.
- Close.
Open.
Bad songs to listen to.
- I have a feeling that's not what happens
and he's playing a joke on us.
I remember I met a really cool girl, Angel
at a conference and she was showing me
how her prosthetic arm worked.
And I remember that it
actually had electrodes
that connected to her arm
that allowed her to control
some of the fingers and
motions that it does.
I don't know if this is the same model
but it was a funny clip nonetheless.
(sad music)
- He lost the weight in the trash can.
He's cutting his calories and watching.
Very specific, I like it.
That reminds me of the
meme with cut my carbs.
Oh, that's good.
I actually have one in my kitchen.
- Things that don't belong
in your body, part seven.
The image behind me is an x-ray
of someone's lower
abdomen and pelvic area.
And yeah.
- Is that a Goop Jade egg?
Because that's what I feel like it is.
And recently they just got
in trouble for something
with this.
Do you not get your
medical advice from Goop.
(techno music)
Someone has really good
control of their scapula
also known as their shoulder blade here.
Interesting.
Something that we look
for in medicine known
as scapular winging where
your scapula on one side
kind of sticks out
almost like that usually
happens as a result
of damage to nerves or
muscles in the area.
But I don't know if that's
what this patient has
or they just have
hyper-mobility of their scapula.
(soft hiphop music)
I feel like this has a medical term.
Macroglossia I believe it's called.
Let's use a little Google search here.
Macroglossia.
Yep.
Macroglossia is a medical term
for an unusually large tongue.
Look at that.
It's like I went to med school and all.
(soft hiphop music)
Now obviously because the
tongue is in your mouth
and it can obstruct your airway.
You can have problems with
breathing, with sleep apnea.
If God forbid you develop
an anaphylactic attack
how much faster that becomes a problem
than the average person is clear.
So you really have to be monitored
and tracked by probably an ear
nose and throat specialist.
If I had a patient like this
I would ask them to have an ENT that they
at least follow up with
on a regular basis.
- So I have dermatographia,
which means whenever
like I touch my skin, it
turns red and freaks out.
So like, you can see,
like I talked to my face
I can write on my skin, which is cool.
But also it can be kind of annoying.
- Yeah. That's that's really
problematic, especially
because their skin is so gentle
that it happens that way.
It's literally happening to pressure
and you get like this
histamine induced response.
I've never seen it to be
so sensitive that you touch
and it happens.
That's really unique.
I have to look more into that.
- [Text-To-Speech] Throw
back to when men didn't know
we had to peel off layers of
our skin after our period.
- I'm assuming this is
has nothing to do with
the menstrual cycle.
This is a, some kind of
mask that they're wearing.
I've done one of these
and it hurts to peel off.
It's a baby.
What sunscreen do you use for him?
I need some for my niece.
(pop music)
None.
No. Vegans need sunscreen because vegans
are still human and have skin.
Especially babies.
Shade is preferable to sunscreen.
So if you're keeping your baby
in the shade, that's okay.
This is misinformation at its finest.
- Mom, I'm in the doctor's office.
I need you to answer a few
questions that I don't remember.
- My favorite is when
like a 17 year old comes
to the doctor and they're
with their parents.
And I ask the patient the
question of what's going on
what seems to be the
problem and right away
the first thing they do
is look at the parent.
Like, wait I'm asking you
you can answer the question you're here
because you want to be here.
But it happens every single time.
- What is my blood type?
I put, okay.
- Who asks for blood type?
And he said, okay.
- Do I have any prior like incidents.
I don't remember having a
concussion that probably
has affected me my whole life.
I'm trying to focus, but
my head hurts probably
from the concussion.
(laughing)
- Was there can concussion
or wasn't there a concussion?
- I've never had a tetanus shot
no one has ever put the tetanus in me.
Tetanus.
You understand that my blood pressure
is going to be through the roof now
because you're making me so upset.
You're making me so.
- This is like definitely inner monologue
for pretty much everyone that
visits a doctor's office.
Most people, when they get a tetanus shot
they get a combined shot.
A tetanus diptheria acellular pertussis.
So they might not know
that it is a tetanus shot.
- My concussion is so strong right now.
- I feel like the word
migraine has now been replaced
by the word concussion in this skit.
- Everybody's saying it's fake.
That I do have a collar bone.
Well I don't.
Look at me.
What do you think about that?
I don't have a collar bone.
- Is this a visual trick?
I don't know.
I don't.
Can you, can you live
without a collarbone?
I mean, yes.
It's not a vital organ.
I just don't know how
comfortable it would be.
And it offers a layer of protection.
I'm going to catalog this one
under TikToks that need further research.
- I like playing this game
called how many minutes
until I pass out.
It's really fun.
But like, low key I feel like
I've been eating six of these a night.
I feel like it like slows my heart down.
- No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
Please do not do this with any medication.
Any supplement do not turn it into a game.
These have serious side effects
especially when it
comes to toxicity levels
of supplements and
melatonin while it is benign
when you take it appropriately
if you take too much it's no
longer a benign substance.
- Hi there.
I'm here to take my
physician licensing exam.
Why are you smiling?
What?
Empty out your pockets.
- That happens all the time.
- Roll up your sleeves.
Do you have any cheat codes
written on your forearms?
- Cheat codes up, up, down,
down patient left, right?
- When you come out here
for your first break
I will state the phrase
"the yellow Eagle flies the farthest"
and you will state in return
"but the great Heron flies further still".
(laughing)
- They do ask weird stuff
when you walk out of the room.
- You get one bathroom break
and you'll have 10 minutes.
There's only a single
stall bathroom for all 50
test takers here today.
Okay. Maybe I should go
before we start that then.
Better make it quick.
We still have to do your retinal scan
and saliva DNA confirmation.
- They do, do a fingerprint.
What's interesting now is
it's all done virtually.
Like my dad just took his boards.
He's doing it from home.
They literally make you
have your webcam on.
No one can walk behind
you or into the shot.
You have to while you sit
down, record with your iPhone
all four directions so they
can see what your testing
environments like.
It's really secure.
Why I never wanted to take
my bathroom breaks here?
A bathroom break is 10 minutes, right?
But the process to walk out of the room
you have to sign out, you
have to get fingerprinted
and they have to ask you some questions.
Then to come back you're waiting online
while everyone else is also waiting online
and your test timer starts running.
So you get this crazy amount of anxiety.
So I was like, you know what?
I'll just hold it.
Thanks.
My bladder didn't say thanks.
Should you shower everyday?
Click here to find out and as
always stay happy and healthy.
(soft hiphop music)